I'm inspired by my a couple things
fired by people I see whether it's in my
home state of New Jersey and people have
met across the country who do remarkable
things against overwhelming odds
ordinary people who are called upon to
do extraordinary things and if they can
do that considering maybe their station
in life and the challenges they face and
yet they do extraordinary things for
people who are we might consider
ordinary people then from my privileged
position of being a united states
senator I have every obligation in the
world to do that and much more so I'm
inspired by the stories of people I meet
at home and across the country and I'm
inspired by people i meet across the
world as a member of the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee and the great
challenges they face in their own
countries in promoting democracy and
promoting human rights and I'm also
inspired by the fact that my view is
that one is obligated to it's personal
philosophy one is obligated to make this
world better than how they inherited it
and and so that's what drives me every
day the inspiration that I take from
people and the view that i have is a
personal philosophy as to why i seek to
be a united states senator in the first
place
I think so I think you're limited only
by you should say I think you create
your own limitations you know I look at
things and say whether it's a problem or
an opportunity what should it be what
can it be and then work from that
backwards and say okay this is what it
should be this is what it can be how do
I make it be those things and I think
that that's the app it is an opportunity
to think big I think it's an opportunity
to you know to do things both at home
and abroad in which you can make you no
significant change I think we're you
know there are things we've been doing
in in this session of the Senate that
move us in that direction of thinking
big that no child in America should go
to sleep at night without health care
coverage Senate just passed that house
passer and fight with the president
about it but ultimately that's thinking
big that no child in America greatest
country in the world goes to sleep at
night without health care I think it's
thinking big that we could create real
quality educational opportunity for
every student America to go to college
as the ability willing to work hard and
give something back to their country I
think we just passed something that's
going to move us in that direction the
greatest amount of resources for that
effort money and since the since the GI
Bill and so I i think there's there's
opportunities to think bad just a
question of do you create your own
limitations
you